j'ai souhaité j'ai souhaité à ce stade
intervenir dans cette séance
pour bien reprise est bien que je les
fais ici même monsieur le président
jeudi dernier quelle est la stratégie du
gouvernement en vous demandant mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs que nous nous
écoutions au moins la gravité d'un
situation le mérite t'elle hier soir
hier soir hier soir je me suis rendu
avec le ministre de la santé à l'hôpital
du sud francilien que beaucoup d'entre
vous connaissent ici je vous assure que
ce que j'ai vu ce que j'ai entendu des
soignants témoigne d'une gravité de la
situation sanitaire dans la prise en
compte est le préalable de toutes les
décisions et de tous les débats que ces
décisions suscite légitimement hier
encore plus de 430 personnes sont mortes
en france
cette maladie touche toutes les tranches
d'âge
même en réanimation hier à corbeil
essonnes dans un état très grave il y
avait des deux patients l'un de 27 ans
l'un de 33 ans
personne n'est à l'abri comme dans tous
les pays
je les ai expliqué et réexpliqué on doit
y naviguer à vue aussi puisque là-bas
aussi le déconfinement a conduit à des
mesures de freinage très lourde voire à
deir confinement la vérité au delà des
polémiques politiciennes
la vérité c'est que cette épidémie cette
deuxième vague est là qu elle est
arrivée beaucoup plus vite et beaucoup
plus fort que tout le monde l'avait
pensé et que nous avons été conduits à
amplifier les mesures que nous avons
prises ces mesures vous la connaissez ça
a été dit par plus d'entre vous cette un
nouveau record finement leur confinement
mesdames et messiers sénateurs c'est
quoi vous le savez c'est faire en sorte
qu on reste chez soi le déconfinement on
est libre de sortir et tous les lieux où
l'on va sont entourés de protocole
sanitaire
la logique du confinement c'est de
laisser le maximum de gens chez eux
d'éviter les flux d'éviter les
interactions qui sont propices à la
propagation équipe épidémie vous avez
parlé à juste titre de d1 confinement
adapté oui nous vous avons écouté nous
oui nous avons tiré les conséquences du
premier du premier confinement écoutez
moi au premier confinement je vous le
rappelle on pouvait déjà allé travailler
déjà prendre les transports en commun
pour aller travailler
y a rien de nouveau au premier
confinement au premier confinement en
revanche nous avions fermé tous les
établissements scolaires et nous en
avons tiré les conclusions parce que
cette décision emporte et vous me l'avez
souvent dit des conséquences extrêmement
préjudiciables notamment pour nos
enfants et des études scientifiques
à commencer par la très sérieuse société
française de pédiatrie nous en dit
surtout ne leur confie n'est pas les
enfants
c'est ce que nous avons fait donc ça
veut dire effectivement que nous avons
moins reconfirmer que la première étape
est donc et donc on ne peut pas aller au
delà la troisième exception confinement
c'était de sortir chez soi pour acheter
des produits de première nécessité pour
manger basescu a maintenu et on l'a
maintenu davantage parce qu'on nous a
dit c'est un débat qui avait peu émergé
à la première phase à la première phase
on avait laissé les grandes surfaces
ouvertes tout rayon c'était déjà il
égalitaire c'était déjà inégalitaire bon
et ça l'est toujours
on en a tiré des conséquences et ce sont
des conséquences adapté mesdames et
messieurs sather parce que ses
conséquences sont cohérentes avec la
décision de sécurité sanitaire puisque
en fermant des rayons dans les grandes
surfaces
nous allons limiter les flux et les
occasions de sorties parce que je le
répète le confinement
c'est de rester chez soi le plus
possible et vous le savez alors pour le
coup pour le coup doit-on accompagner
tous ces secteurs que nous fermons et
qui n'y peuvent rien
c'est un crève coeur ils ne demandent
qu'à bosser et ils ont raison
donc on doit les indemniser et là aussi
d'ailleurs vous l'avez reconnu y at il
un pays en europe qui accompagne au
mieux son économie qui soutient mieux
les secteurs que nous fermons par
nécessité sanitaire
y en at il un seul y en at il un seul je
vous le demande
ce matin le conseil des ministres a
adopté le projet de loi de finances
rectificative numéro 4 qui comprendra
toutes les mesures de soutien que
monsieur a décrites
j'espère que vous le vôtre et j'espère
que vous le vôtre et et tous ses
commerces
on les reçoit on les accompagne on
prépare l'échéance du 12 novembre
mais on ne pourra la tenir que si la
situation sanitaire s'améliorait
je n'ai pas vous le savez une décision
contre eux c'est une décision pour la
santé des français je vous remercie
merci monsieur lévi
[Musique]